Okay, let's cut to the chase: Rayleigh is
a god damn legendary character, that is oozing
charisma, authority and mystery like Trebol
does snort. A character that is respected
by all and has been the main reason that luffy
is now able to challenge actual yonko and
is back on track to becoming pirate king,
after the most traumatic moment in his life.
And so, even though we actually don't know
all to much about his past, I want to use
this chance to not only discuss Rayleigh's
character and his role in the story, but also
delve a bit deeper into the classic trope
of the mentor, and how, if used correctly,
it can enhance the fabric of a story significantly.
Oh yeah, and why the hell is he called the
'dark king'? This is the story of the dark
king, silvers Rayleigh.
First of all, can we all acknowledge just
how fantastic Rayleigh's introduction was
in the story? Out of all the great ones we
have gotten, I'm thinking Kaido, katakuri
or imu, this might have actually been my favorite
one. I by that I man the entire sequence.
It's simply done fantastically, especially
in the anime. There is no music, just that
slave auctioneer suddenly collapsing. Then
we see this giant sitting there, and holy
dawn this huge ass guy must have done something,
right? But he turns around, calls out the
old man sitting next to him for using something
called Haki and then this.
-
This is just the right way to reveal an epic
character like this. This has a real shock
effect. And the way that Rayleigh then enters
the hall later, takes a look at the scene,
deduces what happens, before knocking out
all the guards. how could you not be intrigued
by this mysterious old man, that we now know
was the right hand of the pirate king himself.
-
Rayleigh's name has actually two sources of
inspiration. One is Sir Walter Raleigh, an
English 16th-century explorer and privateer.
And the other is a phenomenon known as"Rayleigh
Scattering". Rayleigh scattering refers to
the scattering of light off of the molecules
of the air, thus changing it wavelength. For
example it's light hitting the molecules in
our atmosphere that give us a blue sky. So
Rayleigh literally scattering Kizaru's light
attacks, seems to be science pun set up by
Oda. The silver in his name of course is a
running theme within the Roger pirates, with
gold Roger, silvers rayleigh and copper Gaban.
Personality wise, as most of the former Roger
pirates we have met, Roger, shanks, oden,
and with the obvious exception of buggy, Rayleigh
is an extremely eccentric, charismatic and
joyful person, that seems to be enjoying life
to its fullest. and since the Roger pirates
in many ways seem to have been quite similar
to the straw hats in terms of their crew dynamics,
it comes as no big surprise that Rayleigh
gets along with all of them quite perfectly
and even more so, is immediately likable for
us readers. After all, this is a guy that
has the exact same values and approach to
life as our heroes, but more powerful, mature
and confident.
And a
detail that I found really interesting in
this context, is that Rayleigh as a character
shares a lot of characteristics with both
zoro and sanji. Hear men out. Just like zoro,
Rayleigh is the first mate of the Roger pirates,
the right hand of the pirate king and the
first person recruited. Both are powerful
swordsmen, that are only second to their captain
in terms of strength. Just like zoro, Rayleigh
also has a scar above his eye, has a bit of
an alcohol problem and just like zoro manages
to get lost a lot, Rayleigh seems to have
a tendency to get shipwrecked, as happens
on his way to Amazon Lilly and after rogers
death, where he is saved by Hachi. And both
seem to enjoy a good battle.
On the other hand, just like sanji, the first
thing Rayleigh says is how much he loves women.
Before showing us his swordsman skills, he
actually stops kizaru, with a quite Sanji-like
kick. Also, as we see in the action house,
he shares sanjis cunningness and tendency
to go on small infiltration missions. He actually
lets himself get captured to steal money from
the slave action that he had lost gambling.
Sanii AND zoro. No wonder you can't help but
find this man awesome.
Now in terms of his role in the story, Rayleigh
in many ways fits the archetypical trope of
the mentor pretty much perfectly. The mentor,
typically is an experienced adviser and confidante
for the protagonist, that passes on his knowledge
and wisdom, so that people can live better
lives and society can improve. This character,
not always, but very often comes in the form
of the wise old man or woman, that is better
skilled, faster and more experienced than
their student and now pass these traits on
to the them. They may have grown too old for
the task or have their own job to do. Famous
examples include, Yoda in Star Wars or Tony
stark in Avengers Endgame, or to go more into
anime, Biscuit in hunter x hunter or all might
in boku no hero. Their role is to introduce
a new skill and or set of ideas and values,
often hoping to pass the torch because they
know their role in the world is coming to
an end. And of course, most of the time, expect
them to have the same elderly, but powerful
look associated with the Grandpa God. I think
you agree, that Rayleigh hits this description
perfectly, though compared to some other mentor
figures, he doesn't have to die to get their
disciple on their feet, we're talking Gandalf,
Dumbledore or Jiraya here. For luffy, this
push is replaced by ace's death, a small twist
on the trope here.
Now, What does this mentor role mean for his
relationship with luffy?
Reighley is pretty much the closest luffy
could get to being mentored by Roger himself.
Rayleigh is a relic of the pirate kings era,
someone who is respected by everyone, even
marines like garp or even kizaru, who doesn't
seem to have a lot of respect for anyone.
Based on the stories he heard from shanks,
as well as his personal experience with luffy,
he believes him to be the man that Roger has
been waiting for. The man, he started the
great pirate era for in the first place. Luffy
wears his former captains hat, has a similarly
quirky crew and most importantly he has the
same dream as Roger, though we still don't
know what that dream is. and so its now coincidence
that rayleigh thinks of rogers last words
after luffy leaves.
-
Luffy has literally inherited rogers will,
and thus Roger didn't die. Now obvoiusly after
the events of sabaody and especially marineford,
rayleigh is fully aware, that luffy won't
be able to continue his journey into the new
world at the level he's currently at. And
so its actually rayleigh that proposes and
sets up the time skip and decides to teach
luffy as much as he can in 2 years, so he
actually has a chance against the monsters
waiting in the new world. and so, not only
does he pass his own knowledge and skills
on to him, but also is the one to mentally
help him recover from his trauma and rekindle
his believe in himself and his ability to
protect his crew.
And in the manner of any good mentor, despite
being enormously strong and respected, his
time is over. And the fact that despite someone
as strong as him being around, the world is
still as messed up as it is, also serves to
show us just how powerful this system is and
how difficult it is to change the world.
-
Okay so that's all nice and well, but let's
talk about the elephant in the room. Why is
this man called the dark king? There have
been a number of speculations about this,
but there are two things here that I want
to highlight. One is the actual meaning of
the Japanese word, meiou. If you watch too
much anime, like I do, you might know the
word maou, which means demon king or devil.
Meiou on the other hand is the literal Japanese
name for pluto, or if you prefer greek over
latin, hades, the king of the underworld.
Now please feel free to theorize as to what
this might mean in the comments, Id love to
hear your ideas. As for me, the quite obvious
meaning here, is that rayleigh, especially
as a user of conquerors haki, was pretty much
a king himself, one of the strongest people
in the world. The fact that this is obviously
not an epithet he picked himself, suggests
to me, that he was seen as the king in rogers
shadow. Almost as powerful, almost as dangerous,
but since Roger was the one who shone the
brightest, rayleigh was the dark king.
I'm gonna assume you haven't seen all my analysis
yet, so click here to check out my playlist!
Also, I wanted to say thank you to all my
patrons and channel members. You guys really
make this possible. If you want to become
a part of the channel, get early access to
my videos and other perks, all while supporting
my work, I invite you to become a channel
member or check out my pattern page. Thanks
for watching. Peace.